cameras are synced I hope because now my
hands really hurt to those of you who
have nine one dialed on your phone and
you're about to hit the one we are not
being held for ransom it's okay we were
in Vegas right now we are in Las Vegas
yes I heard that you like to eat food I
love food pretty much all food but it's
hard to pick what food to eat especially
you know every city well there's a lot
of pressure but I like to see what other
people like I go to those reviews online
reviews baby well today we're just gonna
be using burgers as our test subject
here and we're just gonna try the worst
rated burger we could find versus the
best rated burger we can finest wait
wait before you open there just to smell
em no smelly no don't open it this one
smells bad what's ever in front
immediately smell it that one smells
better I don't know that kind of smells
like the bad burger to me keep your eyes
closed okay take one finger come on put
one finger out and then just touch the
top of the burger and tell me which one
you think it is just the top all directs
you this feels this feels can we just
open our eyes yeah okay yeah bacon is
kind of like cheating here um it
elevates it so much yeah that or what
yeah it does so I think that clearly
equates to like high reviews bacon
equals love the type of cheese is a big
thing even just the color the color on
this you can see this is just like but
you can have cheap cheese and it's still
good definitely yeah but you can tell
with with this like a harsh yellow
versus just like a nice melted like
creamy color yellow is a great phrase so
to make this a little interesting why
don't we do rock-paper-scissors shoot to
decide who gets to eat which burger
ready okay
however we don't be rock-paper-scissors
shoot I'm gonna shoot on that rock
papers
actually wait actually pause I have a
better idea
you guys should close your eyes all
right sadly man we're gonna have some
fun this is the second time Erica's
watching and since you won the rock
paper scissors okay you get to pick left
or right and that's the one you get 5k
so I'll just say left or right and then
we'll both sit up but don't open your
eyes so it's our left huh it's our left
or right oh it's always I was gonna put
myself on it and say you got to eat me
you're laying naked oh yeah what body
part do you get which which one do you
want Chris all right I am going right oh
good I wanted to look interesting three
two one yes excellent
oh I'm sorry that looks really good
what do you want to go first I just was
sitting here in the Commons you like
just in here that's a very nice-looking
bird it has some weight it doesn't look
too big I have a problem with burgers
that are too too juicy here that's
pretty big right
mmm you got a pickle in there I don't
think so oh my I got a pickle that's a
pretty good burger big salt hit big salt
boy loves salt the bacon is really
crispy and that's key that is deserving
of hi reviews ooh we are in a major
American city people come from all over
to eat here definitely over twenty
dollars for sure Jesus burger pricey
burger this is a burger you would order
at arrest 100% yeah what would you give
it out of five how do you ten like if
you were out of you Kendu out of ten I
got really solid 8.72
that's like a b-plus like creeping on a
on an a-minus I think it's your turn
yeah honestly more interested I'm just
gonna keep eating will i well I do this
okay this uh hopefully looks can be
deceiving everyone I was gonna take a
bite is there anything you don't like
gonna burger by the way I don't like
cheese no usually I'm very particular
with cheese so this is gonna be a tough
one to swallow a so much more yeah it
does it it's like you lowered the
saturation took the pricks very pale and
it looks like on camera it looks like
like literally a toy okay just do this
get out of here and you'll do it
I'm trying to I'm like I'm looking
around to make sure I get the best bite
possible it'll we're totally hard for
you to bite in mm-hmm it's not the worst
burger I've ever had okay I think that's
very important to know that cheese is
really hitting me now oh no the pickle
and onion and tomato are saving this for
me lots of water oh that's incredible
thank you so much - can I get one - you
know it falls flat I would not take a
second bite unfortunately a second bite
I'm gonna whitelist that you would you
can have a bite of this really 100% I
kind of do are you gonna taste that one
yeah okay this it's not as bad as you
might think it is but it's not I'm gonna
let me preface and say this though every
place that Eric and I went to is very
clean yeah that's why we're not excited
and totally we're not naming any
restaurants because we don't want to
backtalk any of them so many of the
times people are just bitter then they
got like oh they forgot my ketchup at
one-star relax that was the saddest bite
there's like hopping on this even well
no I don't mean this sighs I mean like
there were no toppings on that side yeah
not good is mmm okay I'm gonna take a
bite out of the best reviewed burger in
Vegas keep it real
mmm-hmm a little messy but I like that
isn't salty - you got the song this
actually has flavor there's something
that that was missing that was just a
bunch of things that should be on a
burger in his own right they just don't
really mesh together well they don't
belong there you can see like proper
slices of bacon - like there's a
thickness to it it's like little too
much sauce I could get messy there the
crisp lettuce which is fine the tomato
the cheese just like melted into the
patty like I was saying that's awesome I
think this was made with speed in mind
and I think when that happens sometimes
the quality can suffer that doesn't make
it a bad burger I'm just saying time
generally equals something is gonna be
probably better I find it hard to
believe that this is the worst burger in
Las Vegas I agree it's not as good as
this one but it's certainly not like oh
my god this is inedible take reviews
that like a surface level there's
probably something there but you just
have to try for yourself every
restaurant probably has it's great dish
and sometimes a burger just isn't it I
mean
[Music]
I'm
[Music]